there is an eerie calm around Malibu the
silence has greater contrast as you can
imagine to the force of nature that tore
through here what it found it destroyed
it tells you something about the surreal
nature of what these fires do that you
look down there and see the patio
furniture the cushions the chairs the
table the barbecue all fine come up here
and the house that that belong to is
gone just the chimneys standing there's
a shower block over there bit of a
tumble dry a bit of a running machine
but very little of what used to be
someone's lives in this very nice part
of Malibu at some point in the next
24-48 hours the people used to live here
we'll come back and we'll find that
there's very little of what they used to
call home now left with the fire closed
in and the evacuation order went out
Rick Cavallari planned to stay
my aunt's house who lives a couple doors
down her house been there since the
fifties burnt down in the ground
I always swore I'd never leave but when
that house across the street was going
up
his house survived most of his neighbors
didn't again you see how random these
fires are that plants survive in this
garden here but clearly that car didn't
you come round and see another building
burnt to the ground you see small bits
of smoke and flame and occasionally you
hear the wind in the trees and that is
the fear and you look over there where
another building burnt to the ground and
that smoke the fear is with that wind
that any of these small fires could
flare up again at any time and you can
hear hear the firefighting helicopters
and planes circling picking up water
from the ocean over there because
they're concerned that this could at any
point become another major fire you can
only imagine what it'll be like to
return to this but at least they're
alive to return Gregg Milam Sky News
Malibu